qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous deviez
endiguer une invasion de cobra à
l'échelle d'une ville bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans ce petit épisode de
socios le quick à la cool on va parler
invasion de nuisibles politiques
publiques et indicateurs quantitatifs
[Musique]
alors ma question initiale ne sortait
pas complètement nulle part puisque
c'est supposément le problème auquel
aurait été confrontée le gouvernement
britannique à l'époque de la domination
coloniale inverse les 1800 qui
s'inquiétait du nombre de cobra qui
proliféraient dans la ville de delhi
pour rappel le cobra ça fait quand même
partie des serpents les plus venimeux au
monde et si généralement ils sont pas
très agressif ils peuvent quand même
attaqué quand ils se sentent en danger
et a même certains de ces saloperies qui
sont capables de lancer leurs cobras à
distance ou tout un bonheur
bon du coup le gouvernement britannique
prend les choses en main et décide
d'offrir une prime à quiconque lui
rapportera un cadavre de cobra qu'est-ce
qui pourrait mal se passer alors au
début la stratégie marche très bien et
la population de serpents réduit à vue
d'oeil mais au bout d'un moment il ya un
nombre de petits malins qui se rendent
compte que c'est quand même un bon moyen
de faire du fric facilement et du coup
ils commencent à faire des élevages de
cobra c'est quand même plus facile pour
récolter la prime en grande quantité bon
évidemment quand le gouvernement
britannique s'aperçoit de ça il stoppe
tout et il arrête complètement de donner
des primes en échange de cadavres de
cobra bas résultat tous les éleveurs de
cobra relâche leurs cobras dans la
nature et on se retrouve avec un nombre
de cobra encore plus élevé qu'au début
de l'opération
c'est con ça cette petite histoire va
donner son nom au phénomène qu'on
appelle l'effet cobra c'est à dire le
fait que parfois en essayant de réduire
un problème eh ben on peut en venir à
l'aggraver encore plus mais c'est pas
tout bon en fait je vous ai peut-être un
peu menti parce que l'histoire que je
viens de vous raconter sur les cobras
elle est peut-être pas complètement vrai
en fait on n'arrive plus vraiment à
trouver les sources de où vient cette
histoire et personne n'a vraiment réussi
à prouver qu'elle était vraiment arrivé
par contre une histoire très similaire
est véritablement arrivé à hanoï au
vietnam au moment de la domination
coloniale française et celle là on en
est sûr l'histoire est un peu la même
sauf que dans ce cas là il fallait tuer
les rats qui proliféraient à hanoi et le
gouvernement français décide de donner
une prime à tous ceux qui tueraient des
rats et en particulier suffisait de
ramener la queue donc on recevait une
récompense chaque fois qu'on a mené au
gouvernement une queue de rat sauf qu'au
bout d'un moment on a commencé à
remarquer qu'ils avaient de plus en plus
de rats sans que qui se baladait dans
les rues d'hanoï et oui parce que les
chasseurs de rats se sont vite aperçus
que si il attrapé les râleurs couper la
queue mais laisser repartir vers leur
laisser plus de chances de se reproduire
et donc plus de chances de récolter plus
de primes on retombe dans exactement le
même type d'effets pervers bon du coup
si on voulait être parfaitement précis
il faudrait plutôt parler des ferrat que
des faits cobra mais que voulez vous il
faut croire que effet cobra c'était
vraiment plus catchy
robot vous écris un gros
défaut on peut aussi entendre parler de
l'effet cobras avec un thé ou cobra
avait craint entre parenthèses ça peut
être une façon de réhabiliter l'histoire
des rats pour aller un peu plus loin en
fait les faits cobra c'est l'un des cas
particuliers de ce qu'on appelle la loi
de campbell du nom du psychologue donald
campbell qui est l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques la loi de campbell
peut donc se résumer ainsi plus un
indicateur social quantitatif est
utilisé comme aide à la décision en
matière de politique sociale plus cet
indicateur est susceptible d'être
manipulés et d'agir comme facteur de
distorsion fo sont ainsi les processus
sociaux qu'il est censé surveiller la
formulation est un peu alambiqué mais je
crois que vous saisissez l'idée parce
que c'est l'une des particularités des
sciences sociales qu'on n'a pas dans les
sciences dites dures comme la physique
par exemple si on physique on calcule
que la vitesse de la lumière et neuf
cent soixante quinze mille fois
supérieure à la vitesse du son bon bah
ça affecte pas la vitesse du son le son
il va pas essayer d'augmenter sa vitesse
pour essayer de réduire cet écart dont
ils sont fous leçon 1 en revanche comme
en sciences sociales on étudie des
humains ces derniers peuvent influencer
les indicateurs à partir du moment où
ils en prennent conscience par exemple
si on évalue la compétence d'un
professeur à la moyenne de ses élèves il
peut être tenté de mettre 20 sur 20 à
tout le monde pour se mettre bien
lui-même bon cela dit la loi de campbell
elle est un peu longue et pas forcément
facile à replacer dans un dîner mondain
si vous ne devait retenir qu'une seule
chose je vous conseille plutôt de
retenir l'une de ses applications les
plus courantes en sciences sociales
qu'on appelle la loi de good heart et
qu'on doit au mathématicien britannique
charles goodhart sa formulation est
plutôt limpide lorsqu'une mesure devient
un objectif elle cesse d'être une bonne
mesure bon en faisant sa loi goodheart
il parlait plutôt de la politique
monétaire britannique mais clairement on
peut l'appliquer à plein d'objets des
sciences sociales en particulier elle
apparaît souvent dans le monde de
l'entreprise lorsqu'on essaie de
maximiser l'efficacité et la
productivité des travailleurs on
s'aperçoit par exemple que si on fait
des rankings entre ses employés ou les
classes du met au moins bon les mettant
en concurrence les uns avec les autres
mais en fait ça a plusieurs effets
pervers parce que ce que les employés
vous étiez de maximiser c'est pas
forcément leur productivité mais c'est
leur note leur ranking quitte à se tirer
dans les pattes or on sait bien qu'au
sein d'une entreprise pour bien produire
et produire efficacement il ya un
certain nombre de tâches qui demandent
de la coopération et du coup là on voit
que la mesure de la productivité
individuelle des employés elle en vient
à être contre-productive pour
l'efficacité totale de l'entreprise une
bonne illustration de la loi de good
heart que j'aime bien c'est celle là on
voit que si une usine de cloud mesure
l'efficacité au nombre de cloud fabriqué
uniquement alors elle va obtenir des
milliers de petits clous minuscule et
al'inverse si elle mesure au poids de
cloud fabriquer elle va obtenir quelques
clous énorme et lourd ans
pour revenir au sujet des politiques
publiques on a vu ce même genre de
problème à la mise en place de ce qu'on
a appelé la politique du chiffre dans la
police où nicolas sarkozy alors l'idée
initiale pouvait être louable c'était
d'avoir des administrations policière
plus performantes en les soumettant une
logique de rentabilité selon leur taux
d'élucidation alors le taux
d'élucidation assez facile c'est le
pourcentage d'affaires qui sont résolus
par exemple si dans une ville vous avez
100 cambriolages et qu'on a trouvé les
coupables pour 40 d'entre eux eh ben on
a un taux d'élucidation de 40% pour ce
type de délit du coup on peut faire des
comparaisons d'une ville à l'autre ou
même d'un service à l'autre en mettant
tout le monde en concurrence en
organisant la compétition par les
chiffres mais là vous voyez venir le
problème quand une mesure devient un
objectif elle cesse d'être une bonne
mesure et oui le problème c'est que les
statistiques de la police elles sont
aussi censés nous donner des
informations notamment sur le taux de
crimes sur le niveau d'insécurité dans
un pays mais quand elles deviennent un
objectif en soi ces statistiques elles
sont plus le reflet de l'activité
policière que de vraiment l'activité
criminelle du pays le problème c'est que
comme ceux qui comptent le plus pour les
administrations policière c'est ce
fameux taux d'élucidation mais elle va
avoir tendance à se concentrer sur ce
qu'on appelle les infractions révélées
par l'action des services les fameux i
ras en gros ça ça va être les usages de
stupéfiant ou les infractions liées au
port d'armes ou faux papiers en gros
tout ce qui est révélé lors des
contrôles d'identité ce type
d'infraction cia as elles ont un énorme
avantage statistique c'est qu'elles ont
un taux d'élucidation de quasiment 100%
bah oui il suffit de constater le délit
et boum l'affairé résolue et en plus il
ya ni enquête ni victime du coup dans le
chiffre global de la délinquance les ir
à s y relève de ouf le taux
d'élucidation imaginez un d'un côté vous
avez une plainte contre x pour viol et
de l'autre vous chopez quelqu'un avec
une boulette de shit boum on fait
l'addition des deux vous avez 50 % taux
d'élucidation sur le service et 50%
c'est un taux qui montre une très très
grosse performance bon je vois que vous
avez compris problème il ya plein
d'autres effets pervers liés à la
politique du chiffre dans la police mais
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails si
vous voulez en savoir plus vous laisse
consulter les sources dans la
description pour finir je voulais vous
partagez la dernière illustration de la
loi de good heart que j'ai rencontré
récemment et c'est à la lecture du livre
détiennent au lion les candidats novices
et professionnels en politique dans
lequel il étudie les députés de la
mandature 2017 2022 alors une des
questions qui se posent notamment dans
le livre c'est comment évaluer
l'efficacité du travail dans des futé on
entend souvent que les députés ils
foutent rien il ya qu'à voir l'assemblée
nationale elle est toujours à moitié
vide mais quand on est un petit peu le
travail parlementaire on sait que c'est
une critique assez naïve en fait
l'essentiel du travail d'un député il se
fait plus tôt lors des commissions et
pas vraiment lors des sessions de vote
au contraire on s'aperçoit que les
députés qui sont là lors des sessions de
vote c'est le plus souvent les députés
les plus jeunes et les plus
inexpérimentés à qui on va demander de
faire acte de présence parce que il faut
quand même voir une majorité pour passer
les lois mais qui sont la faute d'avoir
plus de responsabilités
bon du coup comment mesurer la
productivité d'un député si le nombre
d'heures passées à l'assemblée c'est pas
un bon indicateur est en fait il ya
plusieurs agrégateur qui ont commencé à
répondre à cette question en relevant
plein d'informations sur le travail des
députés alors il ya notamment le nombre
d'heures à passer à l'assemblée mais il
ya aussi le nombre de commissions et il
ya aussi surtout un indicateur comme
beaucoup ici utilisé c'est le nombre
d'amendements qui sont présentés et
signés et c'est vrai que ça c'est un
ordinateur qui sont plutôt intéressant
puisque comme le but d'un député c'est
d'écrire des lois comptez le nombre de
propositions de loi et le nombre
d'amendements qui sont faits par le
député ça semble un bon indicateur de
leur travail parlementaire le problème
c'est que même si on aurait pu espérer
qu'il saute ça les députés eux mêmes ont
pris connaissance de ces agrégateurs et
de ses scores et on est à peu près sûr
que certains d'entre eux se sont mis à
présenter des amendements bidon dans le
seul but de faire augmenter leur score
du coup est-ce qu'on peut toujours
penser que ceux qui déposent le plus
d'amendements sont ceux qui travaillent
le plus pour l'institution parlementaire
vous commencez à connaître le truc quand
une mesure devient un objectif elle
cesse d'être une bonne mesure et de fête
etienne lyon dans son livre il montre
que c'est en fait très compliqué
d'évaluer l'efficacité du travail
parlementaire et que sa demande de
prendre beaucoup d'éléments en ligne de
compte alors faites attention il faut
pas non plus aller trop loin je suis pas
en train de vous dire que toutes les
statistiques sont entièrement à jeter à
la poubelle mais simplement qu'il faut
avoir conscience de comment elles ont
été construites et surtout qu'il est
important de prendre en compte comment
ces statistiques sont comprises est
utilisé par les acteurs qui les
produisent tout ça pour vous dire faites
attention quand vous voulez atteindre un
objectif que l'indicateur de performance
ne prenne pas le pas sur l'objectif lui
même sinon c'est un coup à se retrouver
envahi par des cobras voilà c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que vous aurez
appris des choses n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à mettre un pouce vers le haut
si la vidéo vous a plu moi je vous
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
aventures je vous fais un gros bisou
ciao
[Musique]